take a look at the kid that I'm sticking
on stage next why would I ever do that
you've seen people bomb this kid next
levels it I am a vampire I'm neither
Team Edward or Team Jacob I rooted for
the
sun he was so scary he's scared to
laughs
away I saw you in the back oh yeah I was
the guy who laugh thank you for that you
ever needed an
opener what's up I have a commitment for
you to open up the brand new Russell
Peter special pick and open the one's
going to be appointed for you if you
take me and I will pay for every expense
what do you say all right guy has a
freaking coffin he a good guy and you
can learn a thing or two like what how
to hang upside down I once joined a
doomsday cult by the time I got there
everybody was
dead will you quick the vampire routine
it's not a
routine I mean the glowing eyes contacts
the teeth it's an odd lifestyle choice
but hey it's Vegas but dude you turn
into a bag
[Applause]
dude you're
amazing about you find this kid only
fangs aren't you late for your job at
the truck stop Glory Hall the bide
Twilight don't do
[Music]
this you killed a guy and drank his
blood that's
crazy do you have any idea what it's
like to be emotionally dead inside have
you met me I'm a
[Music]
comedian you want to touch
it